in the old days it was commonplace to
save text as a graphic as you can see
here that doesn't scale well visually
and adds to the page weight and latency
text as graphic can also cause conflicts
with format choice now in theory you
might want to save text in a PNG format
because text has solid color and hard
edges but in this example we've saved as
a JPEG because we're using text over a
photo scale that up and you start to see
artifacts using text as a graphic also
means the text can't be found by search
engines and isn't accessible by screen
readers and other assistive technologies
you can see what the current page looks
like in the text only browser links that
gives a good idea of what screen readers
in search engine web crawlers see well
you can see here is the alt text on the
image says koala nothing else and you
can't copy text as graphic either if you
do need to incorporate text and graphics
over a real text over the top simple
both the photo and the text display and
scale much better and you can select the
text and it's really easy to add effects
with CSS i'm using the lovely lobster
font which is one of the many free web
fonts available file size is smaller too
because we can save the photo as a nice
small jpg for the photo rather than
having to use PNG to cope with texts on
the subject of text and images one way
to ensure your site is really responsive
is not to have any images at all maybe
some of the pages on your website don't
need images these sites use beautiful
typography CSS effects and great layout
to achieve really striking graphical
effects with responsive layouts and
stonking ly fast load times likewise
these sites which use images really
sparingly when you're designing a
responsive site every time you add a
placeholder for an image think about
whether you really need it sometimes the
best image is no image at all in the
past typography on the web
was extremely limited by the number and
quality of fonts available with web
fonts and modern CSS implementations
that's all changed web fonts and CSS
enabled beautiful typography on the web
without having to resort to using text
as graphics